mortal kombat i love this movie so much
you guys
nice thank you yeah we love it too
throughout history different cultures
all over the world
reference a great tournament
of champions that dragon marking
i think it's an invitation to fight for
something known
mortal kombat where does getting the
call saying hey you're gonna be in the
next mortal kombat where does that rank
what did that moment feel like
that was a crazy moment you know i i was
um
i had just gotten back from japan i just
lost a crazy
job a really really high caliber level
job
and i came back and um i was on another
plane i heard that news on a plane to
japan
and i was like devastated i did this
meditation course and i came back
and then um i was on my way to nashville
tennessee
to race cars at nascar and i was like
maybe i'm the first asian person to ever
be in this in this place before
and all of a sudden i get a phone call
uh saying that i got the role
and um nascar
yes that's amazing i was supposed to
race car
not race but just drive a car that day
and i ended up not doing it because i
was like
oh i need to i need to be safe now
because i got an opportunity here i
can't drive any race cars i need to be
in the best health and yeah i mean um it
was a surreal experience and um
i can't describe to you in words what it
felt like
uh but um it felt like a
crazy opportunity and a crazy challenge
at the same time
and um i was inspired inspired after
that moment
miami's a little different i i was
leaving a a series that
was very safe for me and like family and
i didn't have a plan at a time but um i
was i i knew that i wanted to leave and
do action
and like a lot a lot of people were like
it doesn't just work that way you can't
just leave and do action
i was like yeah well okay well you know
i'm gonna i'm gonna try my hand
and uh deep down i was like i'll show
you
um uh that's funny one of them so
i i got the audition and and i i worked
really hard in the audition i did the
work in the quad so much did
the visualizations i i went to the gym
and i i just
like i with everything that i really
want i just assume that i got it and
then
and then if i hear otherwise cool
whatever and um
this one was like they were supposed to
tell me on like a monday or tuesday and
i didn't hear anything i was like oh man
i saw i was kind of getting ner i was
like kind of nerve-wracking
and i remember i was in the gym it's my
day off from shooting and i was um
it was like a wednesday and about one
o'clock in the afternoon and
i got the phone call and i thought i was
going to take it in stride like you know
like
wow this is great you know do like a
woohoo
but i cried i i kind of just
crumbled where i was and i just had to
take a seat for a second and and i
started
i started crying because i've i've been
doing this a long time
you know there's there's a there's
there's a four-year-old kid inside of me
who never feels like he's enough because
his father left him so like there's
there's just pain that i'm dealing with
sometimes you know what i mean and like
and uh when when they say you're enough
sometimes that that feels really good
and um
you know i'm surprised i just shared
that with you but
there there it is there it is and and
and that was my real reaction i i
i broke into two oh thank you for
sharing that
what's one thing that you wanted to get
right for jax because obviously that's a
beloved character that a lot of people
love so what's the one thing you want to
get right there um i definitely i mean
like
there's there's a fine line in between
like you know um
playing what people expect uh and
and and giving the fans what they want
right and so like what so
i tried to walk a fine line in between
giving the fans what they want so i i
studied the game i studied how jax moves
in the game he bounces when he
approaches
uh a lot of the movement is taken
directly from from
the the character objects in the game
then uh the other stuff i structured was
you know
watching hours of footage of joe frazier
and mike tyson
uh and also just the psychological and
emotional aspect
who does this man have to be coming from
[Music]
being this special forces assassin to
moving up to
hunting uh um uh multi-dimensional
assassins and monsters
so psychologically i had to become a
monster in some ways
to be hunting these people so that's
what's when you meet jax that's where
he's at
right so and that has to be that has to
be believable
it had the same marking you do cole
it's a birthmark what do you mean he was
born with it
it's not a birthmark cole means you've
been chosen
louis i'm very curious what the role was
that
you did not get that kind of paved the
way for mortal kombat can you tell us
what it was
uh i i can say it because i think it
came out already um but uh
it was for the role of uh shang chi in
the marvel film
and um a friend of it i haven't heard of
it
a friend of mine simon got that part and
i think he's going to do a fantastic job
with the
material and um everything happens at
the right time at the right reason and
looking back
on on everything that played out i
wouldn't change it in in
for it for an instant um so uh you you
got the right one
i'm very grateful for the opportunity
and i'm very grateful that just diverse
people are are leading you know these
amazing films
and uh to see our faces um that are
usually uh
looked looked over and looked past and
uh to have that opportunity to be a part
of that change
is that i didn't get to see when i was
growing up um i'm honored to do that and
i'm and i'm happy for
everybody else yeah and you're playing a
brand new character in this franchise
and i know these characters are very
beloved to a lot of people so was that
was that something that was like freeing
or did it feel like more pressure to
kind of have to create a new character
it was both pressure and freeing at the
same time you know and
i'm a big fan of the games i've been
playing the game since i was young
we approached the material with respect
and when they first approached me with
the film
i was very interested in the project
obviously but i i didn't jump at the
opportunity to do it because i wanted to
know who was behind it
how they were going to approach the work
um who was choreographing
and and you know um the thing that makes
this movie so great to me
is that everybody on the on the cast and
crew and
and especially the director and the
producers in the studios care
a lot about the franchise and we made
decisions every single day
with that in mind and it's something
that i think shows
in the work not only that but you have
this diverse set of actors
that all have something to prove because
we don't get this opportunity
often and um we want to prove that we
are worthy of being here and um and
and that was a huge part of it and i
think that's why you see the product
that you end up seeing
well i'm out of time but such a pleasure
talking to you guys i wish i had
infinite more minutes and uh
congratulations on the movie i love it
so much
thank you thank you so much i think that
you're uh yeah we're so happy that you
love it
thank you thank you means a lot to us
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
beauty
you